[Musique]
bonjour ou ya steve merci d'être avec
vous puisque vous avez écouté évidemment
tous les trois attentivement cette
interview au site qu'est ce que vous en
avez retenu quels ont été les temps
forts c'était très bien organisé est ce
qu'on peut retenir un bon sens et on a
revu un peu cette singularité cette voie
singulière de 2 du candidat communiste
dans le paysage politique aujourd'hui
alors il affine annonce hurle sur le
plateau de public sénat il s'est adressé
aux petits prades patron en eau aux pme
et aux indépendants c'est pas
l'électorat historique du parti
communiste sylla il propose un prêt de
200 milliards d'euros pour ces petits
patrons comme le pge mais alors c'est
c'est une rampe à rembourser 1 ce prêt
ces petits patrons isseu donc c'est
complètement différent du p je le paye
eux c'était 300 milliards d'euros lui
propose 200 milliards d'euros c'est un
prêt à taux négatifs ce qui veut dire et
mac ce sera le contribuable contribuable
qui devra mettre la main à la poche et
puis il est revenu aussi sur le sujet de
l'immigration il propose la
régularisation de tous les sans papiers
sans distinction c'est une manière aussi
bien de trancher de rappeler à certains
qu'ils accusent parfois d'être de droite
et mac il est aussi très à gauche sur ce
sujet sensible actuellement et puis il
ya la signature fabien roussel ré
signature du parti communiste
actuellement sur le nucléaire sur
l'énergie pas de réindustralisation
france en parc nucléaire
rénover 1 c'est ce qui dit ils mentent
aux français il sait qui bien c'est jean
luc mélenchon sait les écolos tout ça il
à dire il appelait tout ça fabien
roussel qui remet à une pièce dans la
machine sur cette question de l'énergie
l'union à gauche c'est pas pour tout de
suite et ne sera pas non plus pour
l'initiative sans doute donc on va y
revenir effectivement parce qu'il a
beaucoup tapé sur jean luc mélenchon et
et yannick jadot moins sûr sur un dragon
va revenir là dessus vous et benjamin
qu'avez vous pensé de cette interview
oui en effet il a rappelé je dirais les
fondamentaux qui sont aujourd'hui celles
de la candidature communiste il ya d'un
côté un retour aux valeurs aux grandes
valeurs universelles de la gauche donc
l'eau reçu de ce qu'on appelle
trivialement rookies mais tu sais qui
aujourd'hui peut être porté de manière
plus ou moins claires par certaines
formations politiques
c'est le première élément de distinction
et ensuite ça a été évoqué une volonté
de montrer que pour le coup on a un
parti communiste dans une forme de
pragmatisme par rapport à la ligne qui a
pu jadis être la sienne sur l'entreprise
mais également en montrant que sur le
nucléaire c'est pas d'idéologie c'est
pour le coup une position pratique ça ça
peut mordre en effet dans une grande
partie de la gauche parce que quand vous
prenez aujourd'hui les enquêtes qui sont
faits sur l'électorat payer que sur les
sujets économiques on a une opinion qui
est plutôt très à gauche en revanche sur
les sujets sociétaux et bien on a une
offre politique qui est plus de droite
en réalité sur les sujets laïcité et
cetera parce que c'est des territoires
fin des terres qui ont été abandonnés
par la gauche là dessus le logiciel
roussel et bien essaye de morts des deux
côtés très à gauche sur l'économie et en
même temps républicain classique sur les
valeurs de la république mais on va
écouter fabien roussel sur le nucléaire
dans quelques secondes mais d'abord yves
d'abord un mot général sur vous qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette
interview il est assez fidèle à sa
doctrine c'est à dire qu'effectivement
il se distingue à gauche maintenant ce
qui va être intéressant c'est de savoir
si le parti communiste à prendre sa
revanche sur des années de domination du
parti socialiste dans la mesure où parti
socialiste étant en déclin
et
qui fabien roussel a l'air de d'avoir
une voix et une petite partition un peu
distinctes si vous voulez c'est vrai
qu'on renoue avec une gauche qui est
plus proche de la préoccupation des gens
qui est assez pragmatique on est loin de
la bogossitude défendu par jadot
mélenchon
hidalgo et s'ils en sont là cela c'est
parce que ils ont perdu le peuple en
gros ils se sont tournés vers des
minorités se sont tournés vers des
idéologies et surtout d'aider je lirai
des punchline qui sont loin des
préoccupations des gens et justement on
va l'écouter fabien hauts-de-seine sur
le nucléaire parce qu'effectivement il
s'est beaucoup des marques et là dessus
de yannick jadot et de jean luc
mélenchon l'écoutent
en normandie je préfère mille fois
investir dans deux centrales dans deux
réacteurs à penly et arrêter d'investir
dans des 1 0 rennes offshore sur la mer
qui vont empêcher les marins pêcheurs de
pouvoir développer leurs activités qui
vont même bousculé la biodiversité
marine et je laisse par contre à jean
luc mélenchon et aux autres à défendre
ce projet là mais moi c'est pas du tout
le mien voilà on entend y villa il avait
pris ses distances sur tout alors c'est
un peu longtemps sur le nucléaire qui
devait songer nucléaire choix il ya beau
y il a beaucoup insisté sur les
différences oui alors c'est ça qui est
intéressant et on va voir comment ça se
traduit après quand les législatives
vont approcher parce qu'il ya les
législatives 50 jours en 45 jours après
la présidentielle et
est-ce que ils vont se retrouver face à
face dans les circonscriptions
législatives
on va voir pour le pour l'heure il est
fidèle au sila sur le nucléaire à ce
qu'il a toujours dit dire qu'il a
toujours été
d'ailleurs dans une logique du
communisme
qui est toujours été pro atome et en
phase aussi avec la cgt de ce point de
vue parce que le nucléaire c'est pas
seulement de la production d'électricité
décarbonée c'est aussi de l'emploi et
c'est aussi la façon de préserver des
emplois alors que on voit la douleur
quand on ferme des centrales nucléaires
comme celle de fessenheim qui coûtent
évidemment en emploi et puis à le
réalisme aussi qu'il a qui l'a démontré
en disant voilà on aura besoin de 100 %
nucléaire d'ici à la 30 ou 40 ans et ce
sans % de nucléaire est bon on peut pas
le produire si on se passe du
centre saint cloud il est électrique on
peut pas le produit
il est de bon sens là dessus c'est pas
pour ça qu'il rejette d'ailleurs le mix
énergétique mais
je crois que là il ya quand même des
paroles qui parle aux gens beaucoup plus
que
cette espèce de je dirais dire d'horizon
qui est pour le moins floue qui est
défendue par le reste de la gauche lui
dit c'est du pragmatisme le nucléaire on
va en avoir besoin on peut pas on peut
pas s'en passer et on peut pas non plus
baisser la part du nucléaire bah c'est
compliqué on peut la bc de toute façon
ne fera pas faire que du nucléaire si
vous prenez le scénario rte on a besoin
quand même d'un investissement dans les
énergies dans les énergies renouvelables
pour maintenir lorsque d'un point de vue
pratique on peut pas construire cette
centrale en aussi peu de temps donc à
partir de là il ya nécessité d'avoir ce
mix de la met en effet si vous voulez
continuer à avoir une économie à bas
coûts enfin une énergie à bas coûts si
vous voulez continuer donc à avoir une
réindustrialisation du pays si vous
voulez espérer une croissance économique
de demain vous allez avoir besoin du
nucléaire et donc à partir de là vous
allez deux éléments qui rentrent en jeu
si vous êtes un partisan de la
décroissance et si vous jugez que sur le
nucléaire les risques et ils existent
sont plus importants que les bénéfices à
ce moment là vous êtes dans une
perspective sortie si jamais vous
considérez que au contraire il faut
faire confiance aux progrès si vous
considérez que d'un autre côté et bien
l'économie la croissance fut-elle verte
s'est malgré tout important eh bien vous
êtes aujourd'hui pour le nucléaire à
gauche cette distinction là elle n'est
pas seulement pragmatique elle est
réellement philosophique et aujourd'hui
elle déchire une grande partie de la
gauche et pour le coup et bien on sèl
est assez et une incarnation assez pur
de cette première tradition de gauche
très progressiste et productiviste c'est
aux activistes qu'ils ont fait a été
celle de la gauche jusque dans les
années 80 ans est sûre il y 10 1 sur le
nucléaire et dit moi je discute avec
emmanuel macron ils ont des positions
similaires sur le fait qu'il faut
investir dans le nucléaire la seule
différence c'est que l'huile et pour
libéraliser le marché de l'énergie moi
je dis faut nationaliser des oui alors
voilà il est pareil il est je dirais que
il est aussi en phase avec l'idéologie
communiste c'est à dire que les
communistes c'est la maîtrise par l'état
des moyens de production donc là c'était
assez conforme à la doctrine qui
consiste à ce que ce soit étatisé
d'ailleurs il n'a pas caché il a dit que
si
davanture il arrivait au pouvoir livrer
des nationalisations il faudra s'y
attendre je pense que ça sera pas
uniquement dans le nucléaire ça sera
vraisemblablement dans beaucoup de
secteurs d'activité après sur le
nucléaire aujourd'hui même la droite est
aligné sur le fait qu'il ya clairement
un problème c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui se passe vous avez un
opérateur historique edf qui revend à
des coûts souvent à perte à des
opérateurs privés au nom de la
concurrence imposée au niveau européen
de l'énergie qui ensuite est revendue
avec du coup un surcoût donc le système
est fondamentalement dysfonctionnelle ça
pue en réalité sur des règles de
concurrence européennes mais au vu de la
position qui était celle de la france
sur le nucléaire au vu de la position de
leader d'edf là c'est très clairement
pour notre pays se tiraient une balle
dans le pied aujourd'hui c'est pas
contester ni à gauche ni à droite le
vrai problème c'est faire bouger les
règles européennes
ce évidemment sur le quoi emmanuel
macron et bien n'est pas tout à fait
raccord donc là il ya un angle d'attaqué
pour les différentes oppositions à
droite et à gauche qui peut être
extrêmement difficile à tenir pour le
président de la république alors sur
cette question de l'écologie il envoyait
aussi un message notamment à yannick
jadot on va l'écouter parce que lui il
se revendique de l'écologie populaire
fabien roussel et pour lui et nick
shadow c'est l'écologie punitive on
écoute moi je suis pour lutter contre la
pollution et faire en sorte que les
voitures polluantes ne viennent plus
dans ces métropoles mais méfaits jeu 2
je mets en place une prime à la
conversion pour des véhicules d'occasion
de 10000 euros pour permettre à ces gens
à ces personnes de changer de véhicule
polluant véhicules propres pour qu'ils
aient toujours droit à la mobilité et
puis j'avais style dans les transports
collectifs en les rendant gratuit les
verts ne veulent pas parler entendu ne
veut pas entendre parler de transport
gratuit c'est incroyable ça c'est
pourtant il n'est de pouvoir d'achat et
ses meilleurs moyens d'inciter les gens
à ne pas prendre leur véhicule bon là le
message politique et les clés arrive moi
je suis les fabiens au clj moi je suis
l'écologie populaire et
vers eux ils s'adressent à ceux qui ont
tout y passe et ça c'est bien sûr c'est
bon alors il ya une limite à ce qu'il
dit là mon avis c'est l'histoire de la
gratuité
l'histoire de la gratuité ça c'est quand
même assez compliqué parce que ça coûte
ça risque de coûter une fortune ça
risquerait de coûter une fortune à la
collectivité
et je crois pas que le transport gratuit
soit
la solution en revanche il est soucieux
de faire en sorte que les centres villes
soient accessibles aux gens qui habitent
en grande banlieue en périphérie des
villes ce qu'il est là aussi la rupture
elle est là la rupture le mouvement des
gilet jaune le mouvement ces mouvements
qui sont un peu disparate qu'on voit
aussi poindre d'une certaine façon et de
façon assez étonnante au canada là ces
derniers jours ce sont des mouvements
qui sont anti justement qui s'opposent à
cette nouvelle idéologie qui consiste
a plaidé pour la décroissance
et qui finalement pénalise les plus les
plus modestes il a réactivé un peu ce
clivage écologie populaire versus
technologie écologie punitive will et
réactive alors il n'est jamais tout à
fait mort c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
très clairement vous n'avez plus grand
grand monde sur l'échiquier politique
pour se dire entier écologistes pour
nier le réchauffement climatique etc la
vraie fracture qui parcourt à la fois la
gauche et la droite c'est justement
cette fracture là entre d'un côté et
bien une écologie qui se voudrait une
écologie progressiste qui parient sur
les nouvelles technologies qui parient
sur également une approche qui souhaite
une approche incitative et de l'autre
une écologie qui se veut plus
décroissante punitive par rapport à ça
vous avez en effet pour le parti
communiste aujourd'hui pour fabien
roussel une carte à jouer parce que la
gauche de manière générale est plutôt
sur la première approche plutôt sur une
approche écologie punitive après ce type
de proposition si vous voulez manqué
marque également on peut là on peut la
relier à ce cas la question que vous lui
posiez notamment sur la réinstallation
des médecins est-ce qu'il faut une
réinstallation un peu autoritaire est ce
qu'il faut qu'elle soit incitative et
cetera aujourd'hui on a une difficulté à
penser la ruralité c'est pas vrai que à
gauche c'est également vrai à droite
mais là vous voyez avec le parti
communiste vous avez quand même une
difficulté parce qu'en réalité il ya
cette idée qu'il y ait du périurbain
qu'il y à du métropolitain qu'il faut
construire du lien entre le
métropolitain et le périurbain mais de
l'autre côté la ruralité qui peut être
une chance pour justement arrivé à
disposer d'une meilleure je tirais une
meilleure diffusion de la population et
des savoir-faire et de l'activité sur le
territoire et bien cet aspect là
aujourd'hui manque dans le discours
politique parler de la question mais du
coup ça un peu en même temps peut-être
sur cette question de la liberté
d'installation des médecins style de la
perdre les deux amériques ocs et un peu
c'est un problème que tout le monde
essaie de traiter mais on n'a jamais
vraiment résolu le problème hein ça
concerne aujourd'hui une commune sur
trois les déserts médicaux ces 8
millions de français 8 millions de
francs sapho faut avoir ce chiffre en
tête ce que dit fabien horth lci propose
que chaque étudiant reçoivent 1200 euros
par mois par mois en échange et bayer
devront s'installer dans ces déserts
mini haut pendant trois ans ça rappelle
un peu le processus de l'école normale
supérieure ens on serre la collectivité
en échange eh bien on reçoit une
certaine somme alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que depuis les années 2000
et u14 loi sur ce qui concerne qui
traite de ces déserts médicaux et deux
grands plans santé et on n'y arrive
toujours pas
oui non c'est sûr en fait ce qu'ils
proposent alors j'entends des blâmes
pécresse ya pas très longtemps elle
propose un peu la même chose un de
2,2 d'aider les étudiants mais en
contrepartie étudiants il semble
effectivement et en contrepartie bas ils
doivent la collectivité d'aller
s'installer tout c'est tous ces
dispositifs sincèrement ils ont été plus
ou moins d'ailleurs mises en oeuvre par
le passé ça n'a jamais marché
je pense que la solution la meilleure
des solutions c'est dire des
collectivités territoriales c'est à dire
que l est à l'oeuvre actuellement
d'ailleurs c'est le salariat bah c'est
le salariat ce qui est dément d'ailleurs
quand on pense que quand on veut être
médecin et jadis quand on voulait être
médecin c'est justement pour avoir son
indépendance et pour pas dépendre de
l'état ou au moins de la puissance
publique maintenant les médecins qui
vont s'installer dans ces déserts
médicaux ils dépendent de la
municipalité puisqu'ils sont logés
la plupart du temps ils sont rémunérés
non pas à l'acte mais ils sont rémunérés
mensuellement comme n'importe quel
salarié oui on est dans le palliatif à
chaque fois c'est aussi pour ça que ça
marche pas c'est à dire que le vrai
problème c'est un problème
d'attractivité ces territoires si jamais
vous y installer vous retrouver dans une
situation à faible attractivité parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'emploi parce qu'il ya
des services publics qui sont
défaillants parce qu'il ya des
transports également qui sont
défaillants il ya là il ya une nécessité
d'investissements étatique en effet pour
redonner de l'accessibilité à ces
territoires et c'est également un privé
qui doit jouer le jeu parce que il n'ya
pas aujourd'hui quand vous regardez un
petit peu les enquêtes qui sont faites
sur la péréquation territoriale
voyez qu'en réalité ce qui fait la forme
d'unité notre pays ce qui fait que en
réalité on a moins d'inégalités
territoriales par rapport à ce que l'on
peut penser qu'à l'étranger c'est le
salaire des fonctionnaires et le
traitement des retraités parce qu'en
réalité vous avez du coût de l'argent
qui est insufflée dans ces territoires
la met de l'argent ça signifie pas de
l'emploi l'argent ça signifie pas non
plus du service public donc aujourd'hui
il faut l'investissement privé il faut
de l'investissement public pour tout
bêtement et bien que demain des jeunes
médecins aient envie de s'y installer
puisqu'on parle d'emploi un mot un de ce
qu'il a dit puisqu'il a parlé de la
question de la désindustrialisé sur l'or
ce matin dans la voix du nord emmanuel
macron qui est en déplacement dans le
nord pendant deux jours il il annonce
qui aura 4000 emplois qui seront créés
par ce qui a une usine de batteries qui
va s'implanter à dunkerque fabien
hossein ai dit oui c'est bien tout ça
mais dans le même temps il ya beaucoup
d'emplois qui disparaissent il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui délocalisent
et moi je veut interdire les
délocalisations c'est une question de
volonté publique oui d'accord mais bon
ça s'essouffle pas
c'est un peu utopique tout ça si vous
voulez parce que d'abord
j'ai entendu il est pour la
planification alors on est là on est
dans le pur communisme je dirais presque
dans le stalinisme et afin que françois
bayrou est alignée mais non d'accord
mais bon françois bayrou on attend
qu'ils louent qui nous donne ses
recommandations
et le jour où elles seront elles seront
appliquées bain
fut commis
mais là je dirais que fabien roussel il
est tout à fait dans les pures
communiste
j'ose espérer que ça ne
se produira jamais si vous voulez parce
que la liberté d'installation et puis
c'est pas parce que vous relocaliser que
vous défendez votre votre industrie pas
du tout on peut avoir des industries qui
sont à l'étranger mais des industries
qui sont détenues par des capitaux
français il est là le sujet aussi c'est
pas uniquement là la présence sur le
territoire français et un faux-pas faut
pas se tromper
et donc là là je dirais que c'est
vraiment le versant du communisme qui
est assez peu souhaitable ouais un
dernier mot sur ce que dit il depuis le
début en disant oui mais en même temps
c'est le communisme c'est ce que fait le
communiste depuis des années est ce que
du coup fabien roussel son objectif
aussi durant cette élection où les
communistes était absent depuis deux
présidentielles c'est de faire entendre
de re faire entendre le communisme et de
montrer qu'il a une voix singulière et
notamment différente de celle de
jean-luc mélenchon oui alors il faut
entendre ce qu'on entend comme par
communisme c'est à dire que le programme
de fabien roussel aujourd'hui ils les
pitot à la droite de françois mitterrand
en 81 c'est à dire qu'on a quand même
sur tous ces sujets une évolution sur
les sujets économiques et cetera à
l'époque le parti socialiste prenant
corps jusque dans les années 60 70 la
collectivisation des moyens de
production à terme donc on a quand même
aujourd'hui une évolution profonde sur
toutes ces thématiques des partis de
gauche
la réalité c'est que pour fabien roussel
l'objectif c'est de faire entendre une
voix quelque peu dissidente à gauche
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous prenez
les programmes de gauche sur tous les
sujets notamment sur les sujets
sociétaux vous avez une forme
d'unanimisme qu'étant divergences avec
ce que pense une grande partie de
l'électorat de la gauche pour fabien
roussel et pour le parti communiste
cette élection est vu parce que va pas
se mentir et ne pas être au second tour
il va pas non plus faire 15 et même
peut-être 10% mais malgré tout ça permet
dans une ou dix dans une île dans une
élection vous êtes très haut dit vous
êtes très visible de faire valoir un
logiciel qui potentiellement dans
l'électorat de gauche eh bien peut être
important ouah peut même vous permettre
de gagner des points sur vos adversaires
et au delà de la présidentielle là non
plus il faut pas être naïf et à les
législatives il ya une recomposition
partisane qui va suivre par la suite et
donc il ya un bras de fer avec les
autres partis et très rapidement et
louis fabien roussel je pense qu'il joue
aussi le coup d'après si vous voulez
parce qu'il sait très bien que jean luc
mélenchon s'est probablement sa dernière
élection que jean luc mélenchon est
l'incarnation de la france insoumise et
on sait pas du tout ce qui va se passer
après lui et donc revient au sel qui est
jeune il a peut-être aussi une carte à
jouer sur l'avenir pour occuper une
place centrale à gauche alors que bain
mélenchon est vieillissant c'est pas une
insulte que de le dire est que l'ancien
socialiste et est pour le moins
poussif 1
[Musique]